this is though I wear it oh yeah it's
gonna fall
[Music]
hi guys we are high on we are at
BuzzFeed and we're about to play try it
trying to give you up good on my slab
buh-buh-buh no no no wait we did it yes
I did yeah oh gosh it says here
[Music]
I think I know you're going with this
and I don't appreciate it
that was my impression of email this is
a great technique called randomly in
Studio City there was a yard sale and we
have been known to frequent many a yard
sale yes did not know that I was going
to a clean house yard sale saw the
cameras and I was like there's no way
there's also a the loved that show oh I
like the challenge I love that they came
in the valley even eight was so happy
yeah tell you oh this is a great time
day I'm gonna say let's do truth how did
you know what it'll be I think it would
have to be Levi's gotta go truth the
song something to tell you on our new
record something between the title track
the wire is still super fun to play live
and so I've been playing it sometimes
like issue I don't even know coming up
on it's ten years coming up dude got a
dare we got a dare okay ready okay when
we first put that on okay I'm a little
punch and then tips the to move your arm
in wait at the position it there we go
there we go one two we rehearsed
from two to six you know in the morning
Sunday a.m. Sunday morning
the street wasn't completely blocked off
yeah a little puzzle piece of interval
of art and then from 6 o'clock in the
morning till 8 o'clock in the morning it
was completely shut down this little two
block radius we did 15 takes
yes cuz it's all one shot just so you
know everybody wants to leave like after
hours dude where do you play for 45
minutes okay
Alanna is an expert that is pretty
shocking and shocking news
you ready readers all right here we go
Wow and tall here okay again didn't hard
okay here we go
and yeah
comrade we had a sing-along on the way
up to Glastonbury the other day oh gosh
it's this Jenna song Scott man
scoot a little bit dum de dum dum dum de
dum dum this is really scary
I'm walking out of this room right now
I'm walking up this is lifeline hello
Taylor
Hanson I would marry I would shag Zack
and I would either gonna we're both the
oldest y'all are friends yeah you're
great oh nice nice ah everyone in this
room wants to hop this will never end
SC hi you are my oldest sister a cute
and when I need help I come to you for
boy is right of course you do SC hi and
what would I do
I don't know it's really true yours
you're the best the best in the west and
I love you hey
there was one st in the high oh oh I
don't think the band is gonna survive
that's Jake again I'm scared you're fine
oh truth it's definitely a collaborative
effort yes st definitely on our new
video for want you back st came up with
this move this one yeah Francis in the
lights helped us which is Olivia Francis
and also our friend Ian helped us
because there's like of the collab but
the one in a really good turn and you
see I bought it
yes so when uses bought it's like when
you knock it over like is where not
trust me we're me out when you turn you
keep your head you what got one spot I
don't like anything yeah there you go
you will this game oh gee oh wow it's
accounts accounts together and y'all got
it here we all like here together this
week yeah are you three
for a second we thought it was gonna
stay all right thank you I love you
thank you can like I said lady like do
like a Jenga off I'm obsessed with those
girls by the way yeah okay I do that
next time
[Music]